hello everybody I'm John Luke and I'm
joined by Aaron Aaron you got to check
out Rainbow six siege is latest update
shifting tide those tides are so shifty
shifty tides yeah this is a this is year
four season 4 of Rainbow six siege so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna get
through just some basic deets on the
operators really quick and then we'll
kind of tell you what they actually mean
to this game going into this season what
it was like to play them yeah so the
first one is Kali she's the attacker
she's a rich lady from India who owns
her own private military corporation she
is the first character in the game to
have a bolt-action sniper rifle this
sniper rifle is very powerful it can
penetrate multiple walls it is an
automatic down to the body
it'll also penetrate multiple defenders
so if they line up you can actually
potentially win your shot people that's
that's great and it also like it breaks
windows and one hitch breaks floor
hatches in one hit so to back up that
sniper rifle she also has a pretty
pretty good secondary she has the c75
auto pistol and a p226 and then she can
take claymores or breaching charges will
get her explosive lamps gadget in a
second but right now I want to focus on
that bolt-action sniper because there
hasn't been a new weapon in the game for
a while and that seems pretty powerful
obviously I want to know what it's like
to actually play with and against that
thing does it seem as broken in my head
as it might be you know this feels like
one of those high skill ceiling kind of
weapons right we're very good players
are gonna be near unstoppable with it
that's kind of my worry so we played for
about two hours I'm an average level
casual player but we played with some
influencers so some of the footage I'm
going to show you right now is gonna be
the killcam from influencer then being
very good yeah so if you're this good
then it's probably gonna be a very hard
weapon to counter but if you're an
average player who's okay with both
action I mean the time to kill is so
short in siege right that you know
you're taking a bolt-action sniper
indoors and trying to compete with
people with SMGs it's going to be my
yeah it's gonna be tough to get good
enough with it but there will be people
out there there will be people out there
and I'm that makes me a little a little
nervous but it's a pretty that's maybe
the most dramatic addition like weapon
addition just siege in a while that I
feel I could actually really change up
tactics and the way you play it
especially allative a bolt action in
doors I'm imagining I'm gonna be
thinking about long hallways on certain
Maps a lot more now so then let's talk
about her gadget the explosive Lance
it sounds pretty straightforward but it
seems like you did a lot of tests with
its kind of comparing it to other
gadgets and characters so I want you
breakdown with what you've learned her
underbarrel gadget is the lv explosive
Lance
now this is actually pretty interesting
what it does is penetrate reinforced
walls and then destroy the gadgets on
the other side mmm so I think the only
person who's really been able to do this
reliably since the launch of siege was
Thatcher right who I don't see picked
very often anymore
no well although Thatcher does show up
in ranked more often we were told it
destroys meets jammer
Cades electric law and also we didn't
see this in our session but they said it
would destroy
maestro's evil eye oh wow um you know
normal stuff like barbed wire deployable
shields but it does not work and we did
test this on the black mirror okay we
tested it on both reinforced walls and
non reinforced walls and it just doesn't
say I think they felt though that was a
little bit too powerful right I mean I
guess I make sense because the like the
black mirror it's not necessarily an
electrical object so that makes sense
and yeah that would at that point maybe
be too too much yeah so we'll see that
you know usually they put these
operators in the wild and then they
start working on them afterwards let's
move on to the next operator while my
what can you tell me about them so will
my is from the Kenyan Navy special boat
unit he was actually hired by Kali and
lured into her private military
corporation so he's interesting he's
there to screw with attackers he's gay
his gadget is the magnet system just
like it sounds what it does is it
catches any throwables resets their
timer and then
pulls them in and detonates them so it's
one throwable per magnet so we did some
very extensive tests with this character
for example we tested in versus versus
fuses cluster charge and you can build
up enough magnets to stop pieces cluster
charge but it'll only grab one pellet
otherwise per one magnet oh okay
oddly enough it actually does five
direct damage if you throw it at
somebody which was kind of funny if you
get if you get that clip where you
finish somebody with it I'll watch that
yeah exactly
that's just a flex right that really is
what that is so touching on his weapons
just real quick
he has an all-gay - it's rare for a
defender to have an assault rifle and
then he has the same SMG as mute and
then he has a 357 or p12
he also comes with a deployable shield
or barbed wire okay so the magnet this
is gonna be the most fun change to the
meta of the game right because it's just
there to mess with people there's
there's definitely a way to use it in a
way not to use it
so in our tests with the devs we found
that you do not want to put it in the
same room as the room you're defending
because what it'll do is it'll pull in a
flashbang grenade and still flash yeah
if anything you're just bringing the
stuff towards ya so you want to kind of
sneak Li get it kind of in hallways
where you think people are gonna peek
and throw things at you so it pulls it
back into the hallway and kind of turns
a table like like you put it behind them
and then they throw it and then it comes
right back at them totally okay okay
they have enough time to get away they
kind of it's very obvious when it
happens you're throwable early will stop
in midair and then joint towards
wherever the magnet is it was very
effective verse Cappy Taos incendiary
arrows
oh yeah like it it actually isn't just
Thrones it's projectiles so it we tested
it it'll stop ashes breaching charges
mmm it'll grab fuses you know explosive
pucks that come out of his device would
it would it does not grab though there's
a couple characters that they wanted to
balance it against it won't stop Habanos
ex Kairos pellets and it doesn't affect
which his shock drone mm-hmm and
it's hard to stop someone like Jing
who's still a very hard charger because
it'll grab her it'll grab her like
candelabra but a candelabra still spits
out a bunch of smaller charges right so
it's it's basically effective versus
individually thrown projectiles or
individually shot projectiles there's
some sneaky stuff you can do with this
which I'm excited to see people try so
in one test we put it above a breaching
hatch that somebody was gonna breach and
they threw a grenade down and a joint it
back up out of a hatch or you can put it
on the underside of the hatch where they
can't really see it so that you know if
they throw a frag it'll pull the frag
back up to the hatch and if they don't
get out of the way it'll detonate and
potentially kill them yeah yeah
interesting so yeah I think the the most
important thing with the magnet is that
it just kind of reduces trust in
attackers that what they want to do will
happen when it comes to throwable
devices I have a I just thought of
something could you put the magnet next
to the hostage and have them throw a
grenade and have it accidentally kill
the hostage would they get would it
count against them can you do that as a
way to manipulate so you're right on the
magnet is probably the dirtiest trick in
hostage mode because you can put it
right next to the hostage and it'll pull
in you know like imagine if ash fires a
breaching charge anywhere in that room
mm-hmm
it's got maybe a 15 or 20 foot radius
and it'll just pull an attacker
projectiles particularly like lethal
ones right right on the hostage so it's
real dirty when it comes because
presumably you don't want to throw stuff
like that in a hostage situation
but sometimes super like well I know
where the hostage is and I can throw it
in this corner but if you put that
magnet there yeah anyone use players out
there who think you know what you're
doing don't anymore it's a bad idea god
I I'm excited to see that clip so like
overall again I you know I have to go
back to my comments on Kali though I
think the meta depending on what Lobby
you playing with see just so much about
the shooting so less about the gadgets
these days right that in the to our demo
we had to stage it like some I mean
these are us playing with the dev
because people generally at least like
the influencers we're playing with
generally just didn't throw things at us
and sure they're just gunning yeah they
just running gun a lot of them so you
know your mileage may vary depending on
what kind of people you play with but
these two you know again the overall
change to the game now is that you
basically have another Thacher like
character on the field who can get your
help get your team through those
reinforced walls and you now have
somebody who can basically screw with
any attackers that have throw bowls or
projectiles
yeah that's those both sound like really
exciting changes I'm you kind of bring
up an interesting point where I wonder
if it has the adverse effect of even
further discouraging using like
throwables and and more people will just
be only gunning that could potentially
be like a like a setback like it's
forcing people to not even use their gab
just as much but I'm curious how that's
gonna pan out overall that's true and
the my other concern with Kali is that
now that there's even more ways to
counter getting funneled as attackers
and that might just encourage more
roaming on the defender side like if you
can't rely on your walls being
defensible because again like I rarely
see fat rating picked then you know
suddenly why stay in the room I mean I
know outside in as a very effective
defense but also there's this war every
couple seasons between trying to you
know rumors and trappers and trying to
like clamp down on roaming so this feels
like it'll push things a little bit back
more in the roaming direction again
mmm-hmm but we'll see you know once the
general public gets their hands on these
things they tend to get very creative
with the operators yeah
well thank your Aaron for taking the
time to tell us all about the new
operators for shifting tide shifty tides
so shifty and for all further Rainbow
six coverage or any other games please
stay tuned GameSpot
Bradley's victorious hot dogs eliminated